Master P's daughter Tatiana Miller's
cause of death has been revealed I feel
like that trip really opened my mind to
see how I would miss you the most
because you were always here for me five
months following the 29 year old's death
the Los Angeles coroner confirmed she
died from fentanyl intoxication
confirming reports that she died as a
result of drugs we put God first without
that man up above we wouldn't be here
and we realized that wisdom is the most
important thing and that's what we
passed we passed down from generation to
generation back in May Master P shared
the news of Tatiana's death on Instagram
writing in the caption quote our family
is dealing with an overwhelming grief
for the loss of my daughter Tatiana we
respectfully request some privacy so
that our family can grieve we appreciate
all of the prayers love and support at
the time the rapper hinted at what may
have played a part quote mental illness
and substance abuse is a real issue that
we can't be afraid to talk about with
God we will get through this spending
quality time with your kids is going to
make the difference we're not a perfect
family but we love each other and we get
up with Integrity thinking doing the
right thing and I tell anybody Integrity
is doing the right thing when nobody's
watching and so if you're that type of
Father you're going to be all right
Tatiana's struggle with addiction was
documented on WE TV's growing up hip-hop
I feel like I don't need to go to rehab
I feel like I could actually do good
without rehab
her older brother Romeo who also starred
on the show was one of her biggest
support systems even when times got
tough he was supposed to be here we put
everything on hold to make sure you okay
and you're not here I left the Celeb
game early to get here I dropped
everything to get here
I'm Romeo also shared his great
she ate all of the prayers love and
support and although this is sad times
we are forever grateful for the Memories
we did have with our amazing sister and
while he expressed his sadness Romeo
added that he knows she's in a way
better place and finally at peace and
free coming from where I come from
coming from poverty you would think that
you would out live your kids and that
was the mission yeah and I feel like
going to my daughter funeral I feel like
I went to my own film
Master P sat down with Gail King in July
he opened up about turning Tatiana's
painful death into an important Mission
I said let me team up with with nami let
me team up with uh arj cares uh these
These are doctors these are people that
believe we I want to help people that
look like us we want to bring awareness
to this we want to save because my whole
purpose is now is I don't know why you
put me through this God and and I'm not
going to question you but I'm going to
get out here and save Millions I'm gonna
I'm gonna help I'm gonna do something
[Music]
foreign